The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Maybe
I should go over
real quickly what
we did on Monday.
We can start out with we
covered the various parts
of the auditory periphery--
the external, middle,
and inner ears.
And we had a paper on the
function of the external ear
and how it can help you localize
sounds when you distort it
by using clay molds that you
can put in subjects' pinnae.
Your sense of
localization of sounds,
especially those at different
elevation, is all screwed up.
And you can relearn
because you still
have some bends and quirky
geometry in your pinnae.
Even with a little
clay in there,
you can relearn using new
clues to localize sounds
in elevation, but it takes
a little bit of time.
So the subjects in
that paper relearned
how to localize sounds.
Now, there are other
cues that we'll
be dealing with for localization
of sounds in azimuth.
And that's where you
use two separate ears.
For example, if a
sound's off to my right,
it's going to hit
my right ear first.
And then because sound travels
at a finite velocity in air,
it's going to hit
my left ear second.
So there's a delay
between the two ears,
and that's a primary cue
for localizing in azimuth,
in the horizontal plane.
So one comment I
had after class was
that was a good
paper on relearning
sound localization
with new ears.
Someone came up
and said they had
read that in another
discussion group.
And I think it is
a very good paper,
because it deals with the
function of the external ear.
It deals with how you
can relearn new cues.
Let's say if when you grow up,
your pinnae are getting bigger
from being an
infant to an adult.
So you have to relearn
those cues over time.
We talked about the
function of the middle ear,
securing efficient
transmission of sound energy
from air into the
fluid of the inner ear.
And we talked about, of course,
the physical characteristics
of sound, what sound frequency
is, what sound level is.
We talked about
simple sounds-- that
is, pure tones or
single frequencies.
More complex sounds
like musical sounds that
have a bunch of
frequencies, and even speech
sounds that have a whole
bunch of different frequencies
and they're changed
a little bit.
And the change is very
perceptually obvious
in the form of changing from
one vowel to another vowel.
And so another comment I got
by email, someone said, well,
can you tell me
where you're from?
Because you have a
Midwestern accent.
OK, speaking of speech sounds.
And that's a very
interesting comment,
because I've been in the
Boston area since 1983.
And that's 30 years.
And I am from the Midwest.
In fact, I brought my
Midwestern clothes today.
I got my hat and my
Michigan sweatshirt
which I got out of the rag pile.
Or is it my Harvard sweatshirt?
Let's see.
It says, "Harvard,
Michigan of the East."
So I guess it's my
Michigan sweatshirt.
It's got the Michigan
colors, maize and blue.
And so I grew up in
Ann Arbor, Michigan.
I probably-- it
depends on who you are,
you have to sort
of listen for it.
According to my wife I still
have it, and maybe some of you
can hear my Midwestern twang.
So it's an evidence that
you have very good hearing
that you can hear these
different not only vowels
but accents.
So that's kind of
interesting that I
was reading a book
just last week.
And it's called Our Boston.
You can get at the MIT COOP.
And one of the chapters
is on regional accents.
And I'll do a
little reading maybe
just at the very beginning
of this chapter which
talks about regional
accents and linguists.
I'll just read you
the first sentence.
It says, "As most
linguists might tell you,
regional accents are
a lot like underpants.
Everybody has them, and usually
no one notices his or her own.
But the world would be
a very different place
in their absence."
So that's what
regional accents are.
How many of you
guys are linguists,
or interested in linguistics?
Just a few, OK.
Well, of course is it's
a fascinating science,
and it intersects with
the auditory world.
So today we're going to
launch into the next aspect
of the auditory periphery
which is the inner ear.
And the inner ear, the
scientific name, of course,
is the cochlea, from
the Greek snail shell.
We're going to talk about
the anatomy of the cochlea.
This is the cochlea here.
We're going to talk
about the vibration
patterns in the cochlea.
Because of course, the
cochlear structures
are vibrating in
response to sound.
And the original
pioneer in that area
was of course George
von Bekesy, who
was a Hungarian physicist
who worked for the telephone
company, later came to
Harvard and won the Nobel
Prize in 1961.
So we always put him
up on the pedestal
because he is the only
winner for the hearing
field for the Nobel Prize.
So those in the
vision system, you
can pull out all these people
who've won the Nobel Prize.
In the auditory field,
there's one winner.
It's George von Bekesy.
So we'll talk about his work
on cochlear vibration patterns.
Then we'll talk about
the receptor cells
for hearing, which are inner
hair cells and outer hair
cells.
There are two
types, a little bit
like you had the rods
and cones in the retina.
But these have very different
and complementary roles,
and we'll talk about the
separate functions of those two
types of hair cells.
We'll talk about the outer
hair cell electromotility.
We'll go into what that is.
And finally if we
have time, we'll
end up with otoacoustic
emissions, which
are a very interesting research
and clinical tool for testing
here.
So cochlear anatomy,
here is an early drawing
of the cochlea by DeVerny.
Back in the 1600s,
they already knew
that the cochlea was
like a snail shell.
And in the middle of
it, it had a membrane,
and the membrane went all the
way from the base to the apex.
This very basalmost
part is called the hook.
And then the membrane
spirals around
and goes to the very apex.
And so I have a very simple
wire model that I can hold up,
do the same thing.
I can bend it any way I want to.
Here's the hook.
You can see this in
three dimensions here.
OK, so the cochlea
is a spiral shaped
structure which has
a membrane in it.
The name of the
big membrane-- it
has several membranes-- the
name of the big membrane
is called the basilar
membrane, which
of course stands for base.
And we'll see that the hair
cells and the other cells
associated with them sit right
on top of the basilar membrane.
We can go to that
in just a second.
Anatomists more recently
like to cut sections
through structures.
And that's because the light
microscope, the electron
microscope, can resolve
very small things
like cells and parts of cells
very well in thin sections.
So if you cut right down the
middle of that snail shell
and took out a thin section,
you'd get this view.
So of course, all
this gray shading
on the outside and even
parts of the inside is bone.
So this is a bony structure.
It's very different
from the eyeball,
which is all soft tissue.
This is a bony structure.
In the middle, there
is a nerve coming in.
That's the auditory nerve.
The auditory nerve
starts in the cochlea
and sends messages to the
brain, which is down here.
It's been cut away.
You can see the tube of the
snail shell, or cochlea,
is subdivided by this big
membrane, this basilar
membrane.
And that there's another
membrane in here too.
The name of that membrane
is Reissner's membrane,
but it's not that important.
But the picture you
get here sort of
looks like steps on a ladder.
And the Latin name first steps
is "scala"-- or "scalae,"
if it's plural.
This means steps.
For instance, a musical
scale is whole steps,
and every now and
then a half step.
So these, to the
early anatomists,
looked like steps on a ladder.
But actually what they are,
are fluid-filled compartments
separated by membranes.
And there are three
fluid-filled compartments here.
And this is another
cross section
of just one turn of the cochlea.
This compartment is
called scala tympani.
called scala vestibuli.
And this one, which is in the
middle, is called scala media.
So there are three
scalae in the cochlea.
So scala tympani, vestibuli,
and media, or middle.
And the hair cells
sit on this membrane
that separates scala
tympani from scala media.
And the hair cells here,
the inner hair cells
and the outer hair
cells, are surrounded
by a whole bunch of other cells.
And that whole receptor organ
is called the organ of Corti.
So it says that down
here, the organ of Corti.
And Corti was one of the
first Italian anatomists
to really draw the
structure correctly,
although he got it
a little bit wrong.
These round circles are
the outer hair cells.
If you cut this in
cross section and look
at this in a magnified
version, there's
only one inner hair cell.
He put two in his drawing, so
it's a little bit incorrect.
But his name is now
attached to the organ.
The organ of Corti is
where the hair cells are,
and there's a whole bunch
of other supporting cells
that keep the hair
cells in their place.
OK, so the receptor organ
sits on the basilar membrane.
And the organ of Corti's there.
There's this other membrane
that separates scala media
from scala vestibuli.
It's called Reissner's membrane,
but it's not important.
OK, so that's the structure
of the organ of Corti.
And during the 1930s
and '40s, people
started thinking about,
well, how does this thing
move when you stimulate
the ear with sound?
And George von Bekesy,
as I've said before,
was the first to make
really good measurements
of the motion of the basilar
membrane in response to sound.
And this is a cutaway diagram
of his experimental setup.
This is the cochlea
in cross section.
Of course, he had the
whole cochlea there.
And he used cochleas
from cadavers.
He would go to the mortuary,
get a temporal bone
and drill away all the bone
and be left with the cochlea
and put it in his Petri dish.
He had a huge sound
source that he
would apply right
to the oval window.
He would take out the stapes
and drive the cochlear fluids
directly.
And as we said last time,
if you have sound in air
and are trying to
get it in fluid,
you really to crank it up.
And so it's a huge sound source.
And he stimulated
way up at 140 dB,
way at the top end of the
curve we had last time.
He needed to drive
it that high not only
to get sound into
the fluid but also
so that his measurement system
could pick up these movements.
The movements tend to
be very, very small.
In response to sound,
maybe the basilar membrane
is moving only a few nanometers.
OK, but it's going to
move a lot more nanometers
if you blast the heck out of it.
And his observation device was
simply a microscope, a water
immersion lens that he brought
down and focused on the basilar
membrane to see the thing move.
So he didn't have
very good resolution.
Maybe he could only
see micrometers
in terms of movements, so he
had to turn up the sound very
high to get the
thing to vibrate.
So we can criticize
his experiments now
for several reasons.
Number one, we don't
listen way up at 140 dB.
In fact, those kinds
of sounds are actually
damaging to the hair cells.
But we can also say there
weren't any hair cells.
It's a dead preparation.
It's a cochlea
from a cadaver, OK?
And what we know now is that
the movements and vibration
patterns of the cochlea are very
different in a dead preparation
than they are in a
living preparation.
We'll get to that
in just a minute.
In spite of those problems--
I mean, von Bekesy
was working in the '30s.
He didn't have very good
measurement devices,
he had to use what he had.
He discovered some
very important things.
One of the things was that the
basilar membrane-- and here's
a diagram of the
basilar membrane.
It's this horizontal line
here, if there's no sound.
And it's stretched out now as
if you took the snail shell
and unwound the coil and made
it a long, straight basilar
membrane.
So the base is over here
and the apex is up here.
And we think that that doesn't
change the vibration pattern
at all.
The only reason that
the cochlea is coiled
is to save space in your head.
Otherwise, it would
be pretty long.
So unwinding this is
just a convenient way
to look at the
vibration pattern.
He measured in the intact
cochlea, of course.
This pattern of vibration
that von Bekesy observed
was called a traveling wave.
OK, so this-- traveling
waves in the cochlea.
And basically what that means is
these are snapshots-- one, two,
three, and four.
At one instant, the wave
pattern looks like number one.
At the next instant,
it moves, or travels,
and looks like number two,
and so on and so forth,
three and four.
So the traveling wave
starts in the base
and travels up to the apex.
And remember, the
base of the cochlear
is where the input is coming.
If we go back to our first
diagram here, remember,
the stapes is pushing in
and out at the oval window.
And that's way down at
the base of the cochlear.
And what we're seeing
is these vibrations
are traveling from the base
all the way up to the apex,
and it's taking a little
bit of time to do so.
So that's what von
Bekesy discovered--
there's a traveling wave.
The second thing
he discovered is
that the peak of the traveling
wave-- you notice these dash
curves draw the envelope or
the maximal point of movement
of this basilar membrane.
There's a peak of this traveling
when the basilar membrane is
vibrating the most.
That peak changes as a function
of the frequency of the sound
that you used to stimulate
your preparation.
And this diagram shows that, but
I have a little better movie,
or demonstration, that
shows you a traveling wave
that's a little bit
easier to understand.
So I actually have two of them.
These were made by Chris Shera
at Mass Eye and Ear Infirmary.
And again, this is the
basilar membrane stretched out
in a long line from the
base of the cochlea up
to the apex of the cochlear.
And this is a situation
with no sound.
So now we're going to turn on
a sound that is a low frequency
tone.
So tone is synonymous with pure
tone or a single frequency.
So it's just going
to be one frequency.
And the input comes
in here at the stapes.
And you'll see the pattern
of movement of the basilar
membrane in response to
the low frequency tone.
Whoops, pressed
the wrong button.
It takes a little bit of
time for this to develop.
And then you can see the complex
pattern, or traveling wave.
It seems to start here
and go up to here.
It goes up to a peak and
then quickly comes down.
There's almost no movement
right at the apex there.
So one thing about that movement
that I said before is there's
a peak of vibration at a
certain place along the basilar
membrane.
The other thing is that at
any point along the basilar
membrane that's moving, it's
moving as a function of time.
And actually, if you knew what
the frequency of that tone
is and looked at the
frequency of movement here,
it would be the same.
So the basilar membrane
is moving up and down
at the same frequency
as the sound stimulus.
Maybe that'll be a
little bit more clear
when I go to the next one,
because the next movie shows
the basilar membrane vibration
to three tones-- the low one
that we just saw,
a middle frequency
one, and a high frequency one.
And as you can indicate,
you can probably
get from my hand movements,
the low frequency tone
is going to maximally
vibrate here toward the apex.
The middle frequency is going
to be maximally vibrating here,
and the high frequency is going
to be maximally vibrating over
here.
OK, so there's going
to sort of a frequency
analysis along the length
of this basilar membrane.
The other thing I want you
to notice when the movie is
playing is how fast these
three places along the basilar
membrane are moving,
see if they're
moving at the same speed
or at a different speed.
So this is the
one we had before.
This is the middle frequency
and this is the high frequency.
See how much faster this
is going back and forth
than the slow one,
and see that it's
peeking in a different place?
OK.
So this is, we think, due to
the physical characteristics
of the way this
membrane is set up.
For example, down here the
membrane is fairly tense
and it's very short in width.
It's like those little tiny
strings on the piano way
up at the right end of the
piano for the high notes.
And it's naturally going to
vibrate at high frequencies.
When you get up toward
the apex, everything
gets real wide in
terms of the membranes.
The cells get bigger.
Everything's heavier,
and it's naturally
going to vibrate slower.
And it's going to vibrate
best for low frequencies.
OK, so there's this analysis
along the length of the cochlea
in terms of high
frequencies are mapped here,
mid frequencies are mapped
here, and low frequencies
are mapped here.
There is, if you will, a place
code for sound frequency.
So sound frequencies
are broken up
into a place code-- low
frequencies apically,
and higher and higher
frequencies basally.
Secondly, if you buy into
my frequency, or our timing
of the movement, there's
also a timing code
in that high frequencies
are vibrating much quicker
and low frequencies are
vibrating much slower.
And as we'll learn
in a week or two,
the nervous system keeps
track of both of those things.
There are hair cells down here
in the base of your cochlea
which are connected to the
nerve fibers that only innervate
them and are only active when
there's a high frequency sound
stimulus.
They send that
message to the brain.
The brain says, ah, here
are some high frequency
or high pitched sounds.
Conversely, there are
hair cells up here
that are only responding
when the basilar membrane is
stimulated with a low frequency.
And they're telling their
nerve fibers only send
action potentials to the brain
when there's a low frequency
sound stimulus.
So what are examples?
Everybody knows
what a low pitched
and a high pitched sound is.
But for example, one of the
ways you tell a male voice
from a female voice
is that female voices
have higher pitches to
them, higher frequencies,
maybe an octave higher.
So immediately usually,
even over the telephone,
you can tell I'm talking
to a female speaker
because the
frequencies are higher
and they're mapped more toward
the basal end of your cochlea.
Male voices that have
lower frequencies
are mapped to more
apical positions.
Any questions about that?
Now how do we, in the modern
times, well beyond von Bekesy,
how do we measure these motions?
You're sort of taking
it for granted from me
that we can make
these measurements.
Well, von Bekesy used an
ordinary light microscope.
And he really had to
crank things way up
to see the structures moving.
And we want to measure them
down near where we usually
hear, 20 dB SPL, 40 dB SPL.
So what's used is, on
to the basilar membrane,
you put some sort of source.
And maybe in the
1980s and '90s, people
were using radioactive sources
and using the Mossbauer
technique.
They knew that the radioactive
particles being emitted
had a certain frequency, and
when the basilar membrane
was moving toward
you, the frequency
would be changed versus
moving away from you.
Nowadays in the '90s
and 200s, people
are using spots
that they put down,
like little reflective
disks that are put down
onto the basilar membrane
that reflect light.
And you shine down a light
onto the basilar membrane.
And that spot reflects
the light back to you.
You can compare the
light you sent down
with the light that's
reflected back.
If the membrane is
moving away from you,
that light will be
shifted to a higher
wavelength versus if
it's coming toward you,
it'll be a lower wavelength.
And this process is
called interferometry.
And if the source is moving like
the basilar membrane is moving
when you stimulate
it with sound,
you can use a laser
to shine the light,
and you can use the Doppler
interferometer-- which
is a device that measures the
shift in light when there's
a moving light source or
a moving light reflection.
You can calibrate this in
terms of the displacement
or the velocity that the object
doing the reflecting is giving.
It's shifting the
light, basically.
So that's how most modern
experiment experiments measure
of the movement of structures,
even though they're
very, very small movements,
like in terms of nanometers.
So let's see what this-- these
are data from the 1980s using
a Mossbauer technique,
a radioactive source.
So instead of
reflecting light, you're
measuring the emitted
wavelengths of particles
from a radioactive source at one
point on the basilar membrane.
And you're stimulating
the basilar membrane
with sound of
different frequencies,
and you're measuring
how much it moves
in terms of the
basilar membrane.
I think this says displacement.
Is that what it says?
It says amplitude in dB.
This is a displacement
scale, how much movement
you're getting, as a
function of sound frequency
for one particular point
on the basilar membrane.
So you change your
sound frequency.
Start with low
frequencies at 20 dB.
Pretty low level sound.
You don't find
much displacement.
Go up to 6 kilohertz, find
a little bit more movement.
Go up to 10 kilohertz,
it's getting bigger.
And then all of a sudden
at about 16 kilohertz,
you get a huge
amount of movement.
You're right at the peak
of the traveling wave.
Go up to 18 kilohertz and
it goes way back down again.
And 20 kilohertz
there's no point
plotted because you can't
get the thing to move at all.
It's a very
sharply-tuned function
of movement in terms of
the sound frequencies.
This place is only
moving-- or mostly
moving-- for a sound
frequency of 16 kilohertz
in terms of where
the source was.
Change the sound level to
40 or 60 or even 80 dB--
80 dB is a sound
that is certainly
within conversational speech.
It's a high level sound, but
it's not painful or damaging
at all.
In that case, the
function is much broader.
If you just looked at
that function, you'd say,
well, this point on the
basilar membrane years
is responding to many
sound frequencies.
It's not responding
to 20 kilohertz,
but it's responding to
everything below that.
And if you were to-- they
didn't here because they wanted
to take care of
their preparation
and not damage it-- if
they want up to the levels
that von Bekesy used, 140 dB,
it would be completely flat.
And von Bekesy found that the
tuning of the basilar membrane
was very flat, or
just broadly tuned.
But these modern measurements
show extremely sharp functions
for a single point of movement
on the basilar membrane.
This is a plot of the same
data, but plotted a little bit
differently.
This axis is still
sound frequency.
And now we're going to
plot it on the x-axis.
It's still a dB scale,
but now on the y-axis
it's threshold dB SPL.
So what's threshold?
Well in this case, it
doesn't really make sense.
I think it would've been better
to label this some criterion
displacement, because the
criterion displacement
use for this lowest
curve is 0.35 nanometers.
And what the experiment now,
or what the plotting now
is how much sound level do we
have to crank into the system
to get this point on
the basilar membrane
to vibrate 0.35 nanometers?
OK, in the case of 16
kilohertz right here,
at the lowest point, we
only had to put in 10 dB,
not very much sound at all.
At 14 kilohertz,
at 19 kilohertz,
we had to turn the
sound up a little bit.
At 20 kilohertz, we turned
up the sound so much,
but we said could never get
it to vibrate 0.35 nanometers.
So there's no point
plotted there.
At 5 kilohertz, we had to crank
up the sound to about 60 dB
to get this point to
vibrate 0.35 nanometers.
So you're asking for
the point to give you
some specified
amount of vibration
or a criterion of vibration.
And you're plotting
this function here.
And this is a very
important curve.
We'll be seeing this many, many
times the rest of the semester.
And it's called a tuning curve.
So you should all
be familiar with how
this tuning curve is generated.
You can make a tuning curve for
a recording from a hair cell.
You could make a tuning
curve for recording
from a nerve fiber.
Let's say we put on an
electrode in the auditory nerve.
You guys have talked
about this term,
this technique called
single unit recording
where you put an
electrode in a nerve--
say, the optic nerve-- and
you measure the spikes coming
from the single axon that
you're recording from.
And you might say,
well, I'm going
to turn the sound up until
I get 10 spikes per second.
That's my criterion.
And I'm going to
change the frequency.
How much sound level do I
have to stimulate the ear with
to get the auditory nerve fiber
to fire 10 spikes per second?
Well, at 16 kilohertz I have to
hardly put any sound in at all.
But 2 kilohertz, I have
to really blast the thing.
So this auditory nerve
fiber is very tuned
to the sound frequency.
It's sharply tuned, OK, to a
frequency near 16 kilohertz.
You could make a tuning
curve from a receptor cell
by saying how much receptor
potential do I want?
Let's say one microvolt of
response or receptor potential
from the hair cell.
What sort of sound
level do I need
to dial into the ear at
these different frequencies
to get that criterion
receptor potential?
Is that clear?
So these tuning
curves are omnipresent
throughout the auditory pathway.
And they're a measure of
the sharpness of tuning.
They're a measure of whether one
place on the basilar membrane
or one auditory nerve fiber
can listen to 16 kilohertz
and ignore 20 kilohertz.
It's very important
if you're trying
to know in the
pattern of harmonics
that harmonic number
two is missing,
you better listen to
number two with a very
sensitive and
sharply-tuned function.
And you have that in
the auditory system
starting with the vibration
of the basilar membrane.
What are these receptor
cells for hearing?
So the receptor cells for
hearing are called hair cells.
That's kind of a
funny name, right?
But they get their
name from the fact
that they have hairs coming
out the top of them-- at least,
it looked that way to the
early neuroanatomists.
So these hairs are more
properly called stereocilia.
And let me write that
down here, stereocilia.
And even that more proper
term is kind of a misnomer,
because it has as
part of it "cilium."
That's really a misnomer.
What is a cilium on a cell?
Does anybody know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And they can propel single
cells through a medium, right?
And they're wavy and floppy,
and if you look at them
in cross-section of the
electron microscope,
they have these sort of 9
plus 2 tubular arrangements.
The stereociliae do not
look like that at all.
They should be called
stereomicrovilli,
because when you look
at them in cross section
you see all these
filaments but there's
no organization to them.
And you can see the
filaments right here
in longitudinal section going
up into the stereocilia.
And these keep the
stereocilia very stiff.
So when sound comes and
moves a stereocilium,
it's sort of like a telephone
pole in a hurricane.
It pivots around its base,
but it doesn't flop around.
And the base of
these stereocilia
are right as they insert
part of the cell right.
They're very stiff structures.
Furthermore, they're all
attached one to another.
So all the stereocilia
on a hair cell
tend to move together back and
forth in response to sound.
And especially, they're
attached, of course,
at the base, but
they're also attached
at the very tips in
something called tip links.
And I think I have a
picture or a diagram.
So here are some tip links that
connects the very tallest part
of one stereocilium to its next
tallest neighbor stereocilium.
So the whole bundle
of stereocilia
move together in a
rigid, pivoting way.
And the whole bundle
is usually called just
in jargon terms,
the "hair bundle"
at the top of a hair cell.
And I have some numbers for you.
How many stereocilia are there
in the hair bundle of a given
cell?
So there are 40 stereocilia
for one inner hair cell.
We haven't talked
about what these are,
but these are in your cochlea.
They have inner hair cells
and outer hair cells.
And there are about
140 stereocilia
in the hair bundle of a
given outer hair cell.
OK, there are many
stereocilia per cell.
In this cross section, you're
just seeing three rows,
but there are many per row.
And here's a whole big
hair bundle all together.
Now, why are these
exact numbers important?
Well, it isn't that
important, except we
think that the channel that
opens up when this hair
bundle moves in
response to sound
is located right at the
tips of the stereocilia.
And most people
believe that there
is one channel at the tip
of each stereocilium which
would suggest that each outer
hair cell has 140 channels
and each inner hair
cell has 40 channels.
Now, what are these channels?
Sometimes they're called
the transduction channels.
What's transduction?
Anybody?
What's a transducer
in engineering terms?
Anybody?
What does it mean to
transduce something?
Well, you can have-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
So you can have an accelerometer
which converts acceleration
to an electrical signal.
In this case, the
physical energy of sound
is mechanical energy.
It's movement, movement
of the tympanic membrane,
movement of the ossicles,
movement of the basilar
membrane up and down.
These cells are sitting
on the basilar membrane.
And the hair bundle is
moving back and forth.
But the code of the
nervous system--
we've been talking
about spikes--
somehow you have to get
that mechanical energy
into the electrical energy
of, in the case of hair cells,
the receptor potentials, and in
the case of the nerve fibers,
the action potentials
that are going
to send messages to the brain.
So the transduction
channel is the channel
that responds to
mechanical energy
and allows ions to
flow into the hair
cell-- that is, it opens up.
And in the case of these
transduction channels,
it allows positive
ions, mostly potassium
because there is a high
concentration of potassium
in the fluid of scala media.
Remember, these
cells are sitting in
between scala tympani
and scala media.
So scala media is up here.
The transduction channel opens.
And it's relatively
non-selective,
but the big positive-- it's
non-selected for positive ions
or cations.
The big concentration
here is potassium,
so potassium is probably the ion
that flows into the hair cells
when the transduction
channels open up.
And the evidence for that here
is in part from Hudspeth's lab.
He probed around the hair
cells while the hair bundle
was moved back and forth.
And he found big
potentials up near the tips
of the stereocilia and
very small potentials
in the rest of the cell.
So there's very good evidence
that the transduction channels
are at the tips
of the hair cells.
We don't know what the
transduction channels are.
People are actively
working on that.
So there's a guy at
Harvard in the Department
of Neurobiology, Jeff Holt,
who thinks the transduction
channel, this so-called
transmembrane channel, TMC,
of which there are two
varieties, 1 and 2.
It's not clear if
that's actually
the channel or something
associated with the channel.
But when you knock it
out, the hair cells
don't respond anymore.
The animal is deaf.
OK, so these
transmembrane channels
may be the transduction channel,
but the jury is still out.
OK, so let me go back to
our generic hair cell.
We've talked about
the stereocilia
here and their movement.
That's the input end
of the hair cell.
The middle part of the
hair cell has a nucleus.
It has a membrane.
It has mitochondria.
And down here, you
might think of this part
as the output end
of the hair cell.
This is where the hair cell
is giving its information
to the associated nerve fibers.
And there are, interestingly,
two types of nerve fibers.
The one you would
instantly think of
is the afferent nerve fiber,
the auditory nerve fiber,
where the hair cell is sending
messages to the nerve fiber.
And how does one
cell send a message
to another in the
nervous system?
Well, there's a synapse, right?
So there's a hair cell
to nerve fiber synapse.
And that's right here.
And this hair cell then
releases transmitter,
because this is a
chemical synapse.
And it uses a neurotransmitter.
Right, everybody knows
what neurotransmitters are.
The neurotransmitter here
is probably glutamate.
And so that's an excitatory
neurotransmitter.
OK, so the hair cell then
releases the glutamate.
It goes through
the synaptic cleft.
There's a glutamate
receptor that it binds to
on the auditory nerve fiber.
The auditory nerve fiber
is depolarized or excited.
It starts to fire
action potentials.
And then these action
potentials are then
sent down the auditory
nerve and into the brain.
The brain says, aha,
there's a sound.
Now interestingly,
there's another kind
of nerve fiber associated
with many hair cells,
and it's called an
efferent nerve fiber.
So what's the difference between
an afferent and an efferent?
anybody?
AUDIENCE: Directionality
of the cell?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So, which one goes which way.
We've said this one is going--
the afferent is going that way.
The efferent nerve ending
is going the opposite way.
And so most of this
naming nomenclature
comes from the reference
being the brain.
The brain is where
the action is, right?
The cochlea's way out here.
So anything that's
going out from the brain
is efflux or
efferent, so signals
that are going from the brain
out to peripheral structures--
like the hair cells-- travel by
way of efferent nerve fibers,
right?
Another efferent
type of nerve fiber
would be a motor neuron, a
motor neuron sending messages
from the brain out
to the periphery
to contract the muscles.
That'd be another type
of efferent nerve fiber.
So interestingly, the hair
cells have efferent nerve fibers
attached to them, and they form
synapses on the hair cells.
And you do not see this
in the visual system.
You do not see efferent
innervation of the receptor
cells or of the retina at
all in vision, at least
in mammalian systems.
You do see it in
lower vertebrates.
But in mammalian systems,
the auditory hair cells
get an efferent innervation.
There are hair cells as
another part of the inner ear.
We talked about the
vestibular system
and the semicircular canals.
That is a hair cell organ,
and those get efferent nerve
endings from the brain.
And in the sides of the
body in amphibians and fish,
there's a lateral line
system of hair cells
that allows the fish to detect
currents of motion of water.
And those are hair
cell-based receptor organs,
and they get an efferent as
well as an afferent innervation.
So it seems like wherever there
are hair cell-based systems,
the brain sends messages
out to the hair cells
as well as getting information
from the hair cells.
So we'll have a
lecture later on what
these efferent nerves are doing.
I mean, why would the
brain want to control
the auditory periphery?
It's an interesting
question, and maybe there
are several answers to that.
Certainly, the
brain wants to know
what's happening
to the hair cells.
So these afferent nerve
fibers are sending messages
when the hair cell
is stimulated.
So that's the main pathway
going into the brain.
OK, we've talked about
the transduction channels.
We haven't talked about these
little things called tip links.
One idea is that these
links between the tips
of the stereocilia are sort
of like a rope on a trap door.
And when the stereocilium moves,
it opens up the trap door,
and that's what opens
the ion channel.
These little tip
links are something
you see in the
electron microscope.
They're very, very fine.
When you use some chemical
treatment to dissolve those tip
links, the hair cells
don't work anymore.
They don't respond
to sound anymore.
So there are some
other proteins up
there associated with the
transduction channels called
tip links.
That's a very active
area of research now--
what are the
transduction channels?
How do the tip links work?
How are they mechanosensitive?
OK, now let's talk.
We've been alluding to the two
types of hair cells, right?
Outer and inner hair cells.
And all mammals
have these two types
of hair cells, outer
and inner hair cells.
Birds have hair cells that
are also of several classes.
They have what are called
tall and short hair cells.
They're a little bit different
than outer and inner hair
cells.
Reptiles generally have
one type of hair cell.
So the inner and outer hair cell
distinction is true for mammals
mainly.
So how do they get their names?
Well, if you look down on the
top of the organ of Corti--
so this is my wire model.
So this is like the cochlea
we've been looking at.
Now, turn it so you're looking
down from the apex down.
On top of this
membrane, what you
would see if you looked
at one little tiny piece
is a row of inner hair cells
going from the extreme base
to the apex, which would
be this row right here.
And three rows of outer hair
cells, going from the base
to the apex, and it turns
out that the inner hair
cells get their
name because they're
on the inner side of the spiral.
And the outers are on the
outer part of the spiral.
So the inners are
toward the center,
or toward the axis
of the cochlea.
The outers are away from it.
And this view,
looking down on them,
would be looking down
onto their stereocilia.
And these white structures are
the hair bundles-- the tips,
if you will-- of
the stereocilia.
And there's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight
and a half inner
hair cells here.
And in the first row
of outer hair cells,
there's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve.
There's a dozen
outer hair cells.
And their stereocilia
are lined up differently.
They're sort of like inverted
V's on the outer hair cells.
And there's the first
row, the second row,
and the outermost row, the
third row of outer hair cells.
And this is a
stereotyped pattern.
Almost all mammals have this.
In the human, if you go up
into the apex of the cochlea,
sometimes a fourth row of outer
hair cells starts to form,
but it's not very
well organized.
It's sort of patchy.
But you can have a fourth
row of outer hair cells.
If one of these were missing,
the supporting cells nearby
form a little scar in its place.
And we'll talk about things that
kill hair cells in a few weeks.
Loud sounds can kill
your hair cells.
Infectious agents--
meningitis, for example--
can kill your hair cells.
Certain drugs, aminoglycoside
antibiotics like kanamycin
can kill your hair cells.
And the supporting cells
thereby just fill in.
And you can go and look at a
cochlea that has some hair cell
damage.
You can count, you
can see how regular
the array is of hair cells.
And you can count how
many are present there
and how many are damaged.
And you can, you
know, say if there's
a 50% loss of outer
hair cells in row one,
this regularity is so beautiful.
Unfortunately, once
they're killed in a mammal,
they never come back.
You cannot regrow your hair
cells once they've been killed.
In birds, they grow right back.
Takes about three or four weeks.
So you can kill all the
hair cells in a bird cochlea
and come back three
or four weeks later,
and they're all grown back.
In mammals, they
don't grow back.
And so there's a
lot of interest--
Because you have these agents
that kill hair cells-- there's
a lot of interest in, how
can we make our hair cells
grow back after
they've been killed?
And people are thinking
of stem cell approached
or neurotropic drugs
that might be good.
So why don't they grow back?
We don't know that at all.
We do know that,
for example, I'm
in a department called
ENT-- Ear, Nose, and Throat.
Lots of the surgeons
in our department deal
with cancers of the
head and neck, right?
Because there are cancers
that can come up, and surgeons
can take care of that
by taking cancers out.
There are no known cancers
that grow in the inner ear.
It never, ever happens.
So maybe these cells are
so far differentiated
and they've become this
classic inner and outer hair
distinction, they're so evolved
that they can't grow back.
They can't multiply.
They can't form a cancer.
But unfortunately, once
there destroyed by some agent
like a drug, they
can't grow back.
So a way to put new
cells in there that
could become new
hair cells, or a way
to encourage these
supporting cells on the sides
to grow and become hair cells,
is a very interesting idea,
but one that's just in
the research phase now.
OK, so that's the difference
between inner and outer hair
cells.
If you cut them in
the other dimension
and look at them in
the longitudinal plane,
inner and outer hair cells
look completely different.
An inner hair cell
is a big fat cell.
It comes up to a
neck and bulges out
a little bit where the hair
bundle is, way up at the top.
At the bottom of
the inner hair cell,
there's lots of
afferent nerve endings.
Maybe as many as
20 per hair cell.
There's a few efferent
nerve endings,
but they're usually not
on the hair cell itself.
They're on these
afferent terminals.
The efferents come and get
on the afferent terminals.
The outer hair
cells, by contrast,
are completely different.
They're long, test
tube-like shaped cells.
Down at the bottom, they
also have nerve terminals.
Most of the nerve
terminals in this case
are efferent nerve terminals.
How do we know that
they're efferent afferent?
Well, if you look at them
in the electron microscope--
I'll just draw a quick diagram.
Here's the hair cell.
Here's a nerve
terminal coming up.
And here is a whole bunch
of synaptic vesicles
in the hair cell ready to
be released when the hair
cell is stimulated with sound.
Obviously, the transmission
is going that way.
Here's a nerve terminal.
Here's a whole bunch
of synaptic vesicles.
None over here, they're
all on the nerve terminal.
When the message comes
down from the brain,
a whole bunch of
these vesicles are
released onto the hair cell.
OK, so by just looking at the
nerve terminals in the electron
microscope, you can get
an idea of which direction
the transmission is going.
And so label them as either
afferent or efferent.
On the outer hair cells, there
are many, many efferent nerve
terminals on them.
In fact, in the
1970s, it became clear
that almost all afferent
nerve fibers, the ones that
were sending messages
to the brain,
were associated with the inner
hair cells, and only about 5%
of them were associated
with the outer hair cells.
This is was a big
mystery for a while,
and people didn't
believe it at first.
It said, well, all
the information going
into the brain, or
95% percent of it,
is coming from the
inner hair cell.
Huh, that's kind of funny.
There's actually more outer hair
cells than inner hair cells.
So what's going on?
Somebody screwed up
the counts, right?
So it was done over
and over again,
and the counts came
back correctly.
So how do we interpret that now?
Well, about the same time in the
early 1980s, a very interesting
property of outer hair
cells was noticed.
It was noticed that outer hair
cells are actually motile.
They can move.
And this was first discovered
by Joe Santos Saatchi and others
in the early 1980s.
And this discovery was made
when they put a hair cell
in a fluid of high potassium,
lots of potassium here.
There are some
potassium channels
in the sides of the cell.
Potassium went in.
When you have positive
ions coming into a cell,
the cell depolarizes.
It might have started out
at minus 80 millivolts.
In the high potassium solution,
it may have gone to minus 50
millivolts or maybe
even 0 millivolts.
Bill Brownell and Joe Santos,
when they saw this happen,
they saw the cell shrink.
It was, let's say, five
micrometers in length before.
They put it in the potassium
solution, it became four.
Take it out of the high
potassium solution,
put it in a regular solution,
it lengthened again.
OK, here is a graph
of those data.
In this case it's a more elegant
experiment where they actually
measured the potential
inside the cell
by putting an electrode into it.
So you can run this
out to your amplifier
and measure the
electrical potential
in terms of the millivolts
of the inside of the cell.
And by putting current down
or coming out of the cell,
you can move the inside of this
potential whatever you want,
whichever way you want.
And in this case, this
x-axis in millivolts
is the potential
inside the hair cell.
The ordinary potential is
about minus 80 millivolts,
about right here.
Minus 180 is a huge
hyperpolarization of the cell.
And plus 0 up to
plus 40 millivolts
is a depolarization of a cell.
Does everybody understand
what we're doing here?
We're changing the
intracellular potential
of the cell in terms
of its millivolts.
And then we're looking
at the change in length.
As you depolarize
the cell, the cell
goes from 0 to negative values.
That's a shortening in
terms of micrometers
of the length of
the outer hair cell.
This is the basal end
where the hair cells are,
this is the apical end where
the stereocilia would be.
OK, so these hair cells
can actually move.
You can do this experiment
with a muscle fiber
and get the same result.
It's a very different
process, but when
you depolarize a muscle cell,
it contracts by actin and myosin
means.
This was very surprising though
to see this in a sensory cell.
Sensory cells aren't
supposed to contract, right?
They figured out that they are.
They can contract.
Now, that means this
outer hair cell--
and I should say
outer hair cell,
these are outer hair
cells because when
you do the same experiment
with an inner hair cell
or any other cell in the body,
you don't get a contraction.
So it's peculiar to
outer hair cells.
Make sure you know that.
Outer hair cells are the
ones that are motile.
This process became
known as electromotility.
OK, so when the inside
voltage is changed,
the length of the outer
hair cells has changed.
So let me give you a
demonstration of this.
I have a nice demonstration
from Joe Santos Saatchi, who
is now at Yale
School of Medicine.
And he made this demonstration.
And it's kind of a
clever demonstration
because you can
see the hair cell,
and it will be moving because
Joe has patched onto the hair
cell with his electrode.
And the electrode is-- usually,
in these kinds of experiments--
is put on a micromanipulator
and it's bolted to the table.
And because that patch
pipette has impaled the cell,
that part of the
cell is just pegged
so it's not going
to move at all.
That's the very
bottom of the cell.
And you'll see a little bit
of a ghost-like image of that.
The rest of the cell is the long
part of the hair cell, and then
the stereocilia, or hair
bundle, right up at the top.
And that part is free to move.
Now, what Joe has done is he's
depolarized and hyperpolarized
the cell using his amplifier.
But he has made that signal
sync'd to a musical signal, OK?
So you'll hear music
on the soundtrack
and you'll see the
hair cell moving.
The music is not directly
stimulating the hair cell
by moving its stereocilia
as normally it would be,
as when we listen to it.
Instead, that music is just in
sync with the electrical signal
manipulating the inside
of the hair cell.
So I'll play that now.
Once again.
OK, so here's the hair cell.
This is the shadow of the
electrode holding this stiff.
This is the main
part of the cell.
These are the stereocilia
right up there.
OK.
So apparently Joe, lectures
to medical students,
says there's a reflex that goes
directly from your hair cells
to your dancing feet.
And apparently, the medical
students believe him.
Anyway, that is
clearly a demonstration
that this electromotility is
much faster than, for example,
the contraction of muscle cells.
Muscle cell contraction, put
it in a dish, or even hair cell
in a dish-- it can be very slow.
This electromotility is
happening at audio frequencies,
right?
Some of those sounds were
thousands of times per second.
So in the early debate
of electromotility,
there were some questions
of how fast this is
and whether it really
manipulates movement
of the hair cells
at audio frequency.
And I think that
kind of demonstration
clearly shows that it does.
So what good is this?
How does this help us
in the sense of hearing?
And what good would it be to
have a motile sensory cell?
Well, the idea is that these
hair cells-- here again
are the inner hair cells and the
three rows of outer hair cells.
Sound comes into the ear.
It moves these membranes.
It moves the hair bundles.
Motion of the hair bundles opens
up these transducer channels
which allow ions to come in
and depolarize the outer hair
cells, let's say.
When the outer hair cells are
depolarized, they shorten.
OK, when the sound
phase reverses,
the hair bundle moves the
other way, the channels close.
The hair cells go back
to their normal length.
And this goes back and
forth, and in the outer hair
cells are getting
longer and shorter.
Somehow, that motion,
that mechanical energy,
adds to the vibration
that was initiated
by the sound in a sort of
an amplification mechanism.
So you then have more vibration.
You then have more bending
of the stereocilia.
You have more depolarizing
of the hair cells.
You have even more
electromotility and sort
of a positive
feedback loop here.
The outer hair cells
then are sometimes
called the cochlear amplifier.
They amplify the vibration
patterns set up by sound
in the cochlea.
So the outer hair
cells are sometimes
nicknamed the
cochlear amplifier.
So what good is a
cochlear amplifier?
Well, you have this ordinary
receptor cell over here.
It doesn't change
its length at all,
but it has all the auditory
nerve fibers linked to it.
Now instead of its stereocilia
moving just a little bit,
it has an amplifier sitting
right next to it and amplifies
to all these membranes.
And the inner hair
cell stereocilia
are really now waving
and back and forth.
They then send their messages
to the auditory nerve fibers,
which send their axons and
messages into the brain.
Your brain says, I hear sound.
Even when it's a
very soft sound,
like a pin dropping-- which,
without the cochlear amplifier,
would be inaudible--
that pin dropping,
that very small mechanical
motion is amplified.
And the inner hair
cells then say,
oh, yes I do hear the sound.
So the function then
of these receptor cells
is very different
than what you have
in vision, where you had
rods and cones, right?
Rods and cones mediate
different types of vision.
In the cochlea, the hair
cells work together.
The outer hair cells ore
the cochlear amplifier
making this thing amplified
more, and more sensitive.
The inner hair cells then
are the major receptor cells
that are sending their
messages to the brain, OK?
So it's really a different
kind of two receptor sense,
if you will, compared to vision.
And that's what this
diagram is supposed to be.
This is very fanciful diagram.
And there's a lot of hand
waving here associated
with how the cochlear
amplifier really works.
This is an unraveled cochlea
from the base to the apex,
and this is how
much displacement
you have-- von Bekesy's
traveling wave envelope,
if you will.
This dashed line is what would
happen if you just put sound in
and there was no amplifier.
And this enhanced solid line
is when you have the outer hair
cells working their
cochlear amplifier magic.
And apparently,
the active region
where the outer hair
cells are most active
is just basal to the peak
of this traveling wave.
And how do we know that?
How do we know that the
outer hair cell cochlear
amplifier is very important?
Well, there are
actually situations
when you can lose
your outer hair cells
and you have pretty intact
inner hair cell population.
So in an animal treated with
the aminoglycocide kanamycin,
it turns out that
the outer hair cells
are a little bit more
sensitive to the kanamycin
then the inner hair cells are.
So if you treat with
just the right dose,
you can find a
place of the cochlea
where there are intact
inner hair cells
and where the outer hair
cells have all been lesioned.
Basal to that, for example,
all the hair cells are gone.
And apical to that, none
of the hair cells are gone.
So in a certain
region of the cochlea
with just the right
dose of kanamycin.
And in those areas, where you
just have inner hair cells
without the outer hair cells,
you have a huge hearing loss.
You're not deaf.
The inner hair cells
are still there
and they're sending their
messages to the brain
by their auditory nerve fibers.
But there's a big
hearing loss because you
have lost the function of
the cohclear amplifier.
And those experiments were
done in the 1970s and '80s.
And they were
criticized by saying,
well, anytime you do
some lesion treatment,
you say you have normal
inner hair cells and outers.
Well, you don't really know the
inner hair cells are normal.
Maybe the drug affected them.
They're still there,
but they're screwed up.
So recently, a much
more elegant way
of doing that same sort
of experiment has come up.
And this is the paper,
the research paper,
that is assigned reading
for today's lecture.
It turns out you can knock
out the cochlear amplifier
by knocking out a particular
protein in the outer hair cells
and have the outer
hair cells still there.
And this work started
out with the discovery
of a protein that's in the
membrane of the outer hair
cells.
So if you look at
the outer hair cells,
there's a lot of
protein in the membrane.
And the protein is found pretty
much nowhere else in the body
and was given the name prestin.
Now, you amateur musicians out
there, when you play a piece--
right?-- at the
beginning of the piece,
at least for classical
music, the composer gives you
an Italian word that says how
fast you should play it, right?
And if it says largo, you're
supposed to play it really
slowly, Right or
adagio, slow, right?
What's the marking or
Italian word for "fast"?
AUDIENCE: Presto.
PROFESSOR: Presto, right.
And this protein
was named prestin
because, at least at the
time it was discovered,
they had the idea that, oh, OK.
Maybe it's the cochlear
amplifier protein
and it makes these outer hair
cells shorten and contract
really quickly, very fast.
So we'll call it prestin.
It turned out that
that was true,
and here's some of the
evidence in support of that.
You can knock out
the gene for prestin.
So a knock-out is an animal
in which a particular gene
is either removed or made so
it doesn't make the protein.
Part of it's deleted, and
so the protein is not made.
You can make a
knock-out mouse where
the prestin is knocked out.
And that's what was
done in this paper.
OK, and in that knock-out
mouse, you can look--
and they looked at a
whole bunch of things.
That looked at the
electromotility the outer hair
cells.
So they took outer hair
cells and put them in a dish
and looked at the kind of
movements we saw in that video.
And in this trace,
this is minus minus,
which is the geneticist
lingo for a knock-out.
Both genes for prestin are gone.
This trace is the plus plus,
the wild type, or normal.
And there's big changes
in outer hair cells
when you depolarize
and hyperpolarize them.
And these big changes are on
the order of half a micrometer.
So this is a length axis.
In the knock-out,
the outer hair cells
don't change length
at all when they're
depolarized and hyperpolarized.
In the heterozygote,
which is the case when
you have one gene
intact for prestin
and the other gene
is knocked out,
it's an intermediate result.
OK, so the outer
hair cell motility
is knocked out by knocking
out this one protein.
So that's pretty good
evidence that it's
involved in the
cochlear amplifier.
What else was measured?
Well, they wanted to
measure hearing sensitivity.
And so in humans,
what you might do
for that is put a subject in
a soundproof chamber and say,
raise your hand when
you hear the sound.
But you could do that in
mice, but it takes a long time
to train mice or other
experimental animals
to do those behavioral tests.
So they did an electro
physiological test.
They measured what's called
the auditory brain stem
response, so the ABR.
This stands for auditory
brain stem response.
OK.
And that top right graph gives
you the ABR threshold in dB.
So something that has
a really low threshold
is a really good hearing animal.
This is the wild type
and the heterozygote.
And something that has
a very high threshold
means you really had
to crank up the sound
to get any kind
of response at all
as you see in the open
symbols for the knock-out.
So how do they measure that ABR?
You could do it in animals
or humans as a clinical test.
Put electrodes on the
surface of the skin.
You turn on a click
or a tone burst.
In this case, they
used tone bursts
of different frequencies.
And you can imagine that the
auditory brain stem is way down
in the head, and you're
measuring on the surface.
So you've got a
click, click, click.
And you measure
thousands of responses.
So there's a lot of noise.
There's noise in the room.
There's noise from other
neurons in the brain.
But eventually, after
thousands of averages,
that little tiny signal
comes out of the noise,
and you get a response if the
brain stem is responding--
that is, if the hair
cells are responding,
the nerve fibers send
messages into the brain stem,
and the brain stem
finally responds.
It's a very good test
of auditory sensitivity.
And what does it show?
It shows that without prestin
in the knock-out animal,
you have a huge hearing loss.
How big is the hearing loss?
Well, looks like it's
about 40 to 60 dB.
So when you have
prestin knocked out,
you have a hearing
loss of 40 to 60 dB.
How much amplification does the
cochlear amplifier give you?
40 to 60 dB.
You're not completely
deaf without it,
but you have a
severe hearing loss.
Most of you would not
be able to understand
what I'm saying with
a 60 dB hearing loss,
unless you were sitting
right up here in the front.
What else do I want to
say about this paper?
Not too much.
There are some problems with it.
Any paper has problems.
They found that,
for some reason,
all the hair cells were lost
for the high frequency basal
part of the cochlea.
It's just a problem in
some strains of mice
that they lose hair cells in
a certain part of the cochlea.
So within these gray bars,
you can't conclude anything.
Now, they looked
at the hair cells.
They just took them
out and looked at them
in the microscope.
And they said, wow,
in the knock-out,
the hair cells are
actually smaller.
Well, you cut out all this
protein from the membrane
in the knock-out, right?
So if there's a lot less
membrane there, they shrink.
The outer hair cell membrane
is packed with prestin.
So you could argue, oh, all
the hair cells are shorter,
and so they're not
working the same way.
Every paper has its problems.
but that's what
these graphs mean.
The hair cells at
rest are actually
shorter in the knock-out.
So just some caveats.
I think the main
message is prestin
is essential for the
cochlear amplifier.
And without it, you have a
big hearing loss, 40 to 60 dB.
Now, one of the other
things they measured in here
is something called
the distortion product
otoacoustic emission.
And let me just, as the last
thing in today's lecture,
tell you about what an
otoacoustic emission is.
These were discovered about the
same time as outer hair cell
electromotility by
David Kemp, who's
at University College London.
And he was doing some kind
of hearing tests in people,
and he developed a very,
very sensitive microphone
that had a very low
electrical noise.
He stuck that microphone
in an ear canal.
And what did he find?
The microphone actually picked
up sound in the ear canal.
Oh my gosh, this is crazy.
There's not supposed to be
sound coming out of the ear,
you're supposed to be putting
sound into the ear, right?
So he named it
otoacoustic emission.
OK, "oto" means ear.
"Acoustic" means sound, and
"emissions" means coming out,
sound coming out of the ear.
This was an amazing
discovery, and it
fits very nicely with
the idea that there's
something in the ear
that's actually moving,
that being the outer hair cells.
The outer hair cells are
moving either spontaneously--
and there are some otoacoustic
emissions that are spontaneous.
About half of us have
spontaneous otoacoustic
emissions in our ears.
Now, before you get too excited
and go home and listen to them,
they are very, very
low levels of sound.
Most of them are below
the audio metric hearing
curve for human hearing.
So you really, in
most cases, are not
aware of your
otoacoustic emissions.
This is very different from
the sensation that some of us
have of ringing in
the ears, tinnitus.
Does anybody have tinnitus?
I have tinnitus,
especially my left ear.
If I close my left ear, often
I can hear kind of a noise.
Put my head on the
pillow at night,
I can hear a little
noise in there.
So that's a sensation
that I have even
though there's no
sound going in my ear,
and it's not an
otoacoustic emission.
You could put a
microphone in that ear,
and there is no sound there.
Something in my brain is telling
me that I am hearing a sound.
Some people are very
disturbed by tinnitus.
There's no good
treatment for it.
Historically, the
famous treatment
was by an ear surgeon who said,
OK, I'll cure your tinnitus.
And he took out the person's
ear, the cochlea was taken out.
Tinnitus didn't change one bit.
Maybe it's like phantom
limb pain, something
to do with your
central nervous system.
Tinnitus and
otoacoustic emissions
are completely different.
Otoacoustic emissions are
associated with normal hearing,
normal outer hair cell function.
They're sometimes used
as a clinical test
for hearing in patients
who can't raise their arm.
For example, most states,
like Massachusetts,
you have to, by law, test
newborns for good hearing.
An otoacoustic
emission test is one.
So how does that work if only
50% of the people have them?
Well, there are other types
of otoacoustic emissions
that are evoked-- that
is, you put sound in,
and you listen for the
sound coming back out.
Some of these are
transiently evoked.
You put a click in, and a
few milliseconds later you
get a sound coming back out.
And that's the
usual clinical test.
And 100% of normal
hearing humans
have these so-called
otoacoustic emissions.
Now, what would be
an indication if you
had a patient with no
otoacoustic emissions?
Well, it is a good test
of whether your middle ear
and inner ear is working
as far along the pathway
as the outer hair cells.
Beyond that, it doesn't test.
It just tests up to
the electromotile part
of the hearing organ.
So it doesn't test
the inner hair cells.
It doesn't test the
auditory nerve fibers.
But much of hearing problem
arises in the outer hair cells,
so it's a pretty
good first step.
It's a very easy test to do.
And I think when we have the
lab tour over at the Mass Eye
and Ear Infirmary at
the end of the semester,
we'll be seeing some
otoacoustic emissions recorded
from a human.
There's a project
going on there now.
So we'll have a demo of that.
OK, so if there
aren't any questions,
we'll meet up again on Monday.